oh yeah so yeah a little bit I should
thank the organizers for putting this
thing together in the in particular for
this workshop is sunray that did the lot
of the work and that and somehow they I
was tricked into giving this talk that
is a little bit embarrassing but you
know other people build out okay so so
I'll try to you know huge myself by
giving a talk that is somehow tutorial
ish and then y'all will give me the
opportunity to cite papers from other
people around here the audience gives
some motivation and then your specific
example and the result and then to to
analysis technique that I think are
interesting and finally a little bit of
applications okay on don't forget even
shorter the required so that we can get
coffee okay no not sure the motivation
is the following so something that we
saw in the morning is that a lot of time
when y'all are nice you know random
instances of sparse graphs a part of the
work is analyzing some tree recursion
and the reason is that locally this
graph converge to three and one way to
make sense of these three recursion is
that they really encode the performance
of some algorithm okay so often the way
you can think about it is that there is
a local algorithm that acts on the graph
and since the graph converges locally
twittery you can analyze the performance
of this algorithm by by by this kind of
trainer shins so one thing that that is
my motivation is that there is no
analogous you know pattern for dense
graph problems although you know
everybody probably agrees that you know
models on this graph should be to be
easier and I want to argue that somehow
one way to do it is through this to this
approximate message passing technology
and and I will start by introducing a
first a simple example in which
chicken I can describe this more
concretely that is much easier than what
talent for instance or 90 talk about and
the problem is this this finding her
planted than subgraph in a random graph
okay so okay so this is the adjacency
matrix of a random graph and that's the
peculiarities of having one sub matrix
that is particularly dancer and and the
name of the gay I want to find the arm
giving such a dangerous and C matrix I
don't know what is the subset the
principal sub matrix it is dance I want
to find the principal sub matrix okay so
let me let me just write the formula so
the the model this is just an example
the model I want to talk about in this
example is the following of a graph for
n vertices that is generated as follows
I select kappa x and vertices uniformly
at random say ok so a small subset of
vertices uniformly at random and then I
lay down edges that are conditionally
independent given the set and the edge
probabilities are the following if the
two vertices both belong to the set the
edge probably it is some constant over n
if they don't belong to the set is some
other constant over and a is like a bit
bigger than beer so you have this kind
of of structure now this is this is you
can think of it as a as a as a sparse
version of the hidden clique problem
very well known hidden click problem
yeah we are looking a sparse version yes
they did it before yeah so now we want
to find this set s you're given a
realization of this graphic you won't
find I said to s and you know but easily
very simply the first heuristic that you
might think of is the following well
vertices that are in the set have a
slightly higher degree than on average
than the others right so particularly
usual it a calculation you show that the
the gree of vertices that out outside
the special set is B
because it's actually by not is a
Poisson random variable with mean be
because each one is connected to either
one of em vertices with probability be
over n so gives person be roughly while
degree in is a little bit larger is B
plus something that is a little bit
larger ok depending on Kappa because
they are you know there are more friends
in the in the in the click ok so this
suggests the following that one test
that you just you know look at the
degree of each vertex and on the basis
of the degree you decide whether it is
if it is above the threshold you see
it's in a special set if it is below the
threshold say it's outside that that's
at and you know more generally we can
formalize it as follows for each vertex
I'm I'm constructing the ball of radius
l around vertex I this is the sub graph
induced by all the vertices that have
distance at most l from vertex I and
then you compute the posterior
probability that the vertex in s given
the ball and that is not unless given
the ball now if you give me these two
numbers I can decide I can take a
decision I'd say for instance if this
number is bigger than this number i
declare that it is in in the set if it
is a smaller i declare it's not in the
set this is the base optimal decision
and the test based on the degree in what
is doing is a special case of this with
l equal one ok so this is an example of
example of a local algorithm is a local
algorithm that you know just look at the
local neighborhood of each vertex I and
decide on the basis of local
neighborhood you can compute stuff about
it here it's a little your Monte Carlo
calculation in which
so I I messed up with the slides so this
is a liquid one I look at depth one
neighborhood so just degree and the red
line is the probability that this
algorithm will succeed as a function of
basically a minus B make some number and
then this is ok so now the caption is
wrong this is a liquid too if you do
with depth to you get some other number
a bit higher succeed in such it exactly
succeed exactly for that vertex so this
is the probability on the fraction of
vertices that you get right if you run
this algorithm pesca and then you repeat
it and then you can let L to infinity
after n to infinity and this is the
right curve is what you get depression
don't know but so now what I what I'm
thinking is that I'm putting the optimal
threshold in the sense so for depth 1
what I'm doing is a very simple game in
which i compute the degree if it's
higher than threshold that declared this
is in the site if it is below it's not
in the set for that 245 I'm computing
the posterior probability that is there
are taxis in the in the set and based on
the posterior probability you do the
optimal decision that is you threshold
that one off this base on already day
what you know about the solution but
yeah is based on oh it's based just on
the baby of cache of the where you have
a guys it's just that one off in this
case once you goes to compute the
posterior it's at one-half ok so ok the
simple example is just to explain this
this style of analysis now first
question that comes up is how you
compute this posterior you have to
compute the posterior probability that
this vertex is in the set s this can be
a priori messy stuff but nicely things
are you know happily things have nice on
trees and this boils down to a recursion
and this is the kind of precautions that
also learn I thought about you can cast
it easy as a message passing algorithm
and this is
belief propagation so this is really
bleep propagation of the posterior graph
posterior distribution of the set s and
then there is another question if you
are not just care about making things
work but also analyzing them how do you
analyze this top type of algorithm well
in this very nice model what happens is
that locally the graph is not tell just
a tree but is a very special and simple
tree it's a gal towards on three so it's
a tree that basically doesn't have
memory and so you can you no
corresponding to this algorithm there is
a distribution or eight caution so what
you want to analyze for analogy the
algorithm is this kind of distribution
of the couch ok so this is a high level
or how you know this style of analysis
works ok so just one slide to show how
this recursion looked like also this
belief propagation reduction this is
similar again to two things that have
been written this morning if you write
it in the right body bolts for instance
for this problem looks like this you
have a variable that you update for each
edge in your graph for each directed
edge and this is a function of of all
the variable and coming through directed
edges at the same vertex ok so you have
a note here I another node J and then
what you do is that you update you
update a message here that depends on
this and this recursion just encodes the
update of these posterior probabilities
so the relation between this and
posterior probabilities is roughly
speaking that Excel I is log of new I
alarm you know for protect L decision 1
divided new il0 these are you know my
updates are in terms of probability
distribution over the set 01 and then
you know makes sense to take log of a
ratio this is what
people call log likelihood ratios and
physicist call magnetic fields and the
function here is this a simple function
is a combination of log and exponential
now when you do there the analysis then
the analysis basically boils down to
considering this X incoming in the same
vertex as independent so now this is
somehow the crux of the matter of the
crux of the talk and this you're what is
done a lot of this paper while they are
they should be independent also this you
heard you had some extended morning is
that is because if you expand down the
three expand down the graph the graph
should look like in large n limit as a
tree and this subtree are disjoint so
whatever function you computed on these
edges are dependent because our function
of this joint and independent sub trees
so this is a very simple justification
in particular tells you that this will
be independent for any fixed T and in
fact any tea that scales when r is less
than a small constant times log n say
they stay still roughly independent so
this is one one basic observation
any question about this
alright so now there are many problems
in which is interesting to think about
dense graph for instance the analogous
of that problem is the case in which is
the current planted clique problem well
now I I for the set has the edge
probabilities one outside sdh prodigies
one-half okay and now the right way to
scale the set there is a constant times
square root of x is not a constant times
n but the constant M square root of n
then your debt anyway is not very
important now everything that I said
below before kind of breaks down right
because because you don't lot longer
I've you know a tree and you don't no
longer live convergence to a gal to
Watson three in particular okay I no
longer you have independence of these
incoming messages and no longer you have
a reasonable notion of what a local
algorithm is so I want to argue that
still there is the restoring similar so
what I'll do is just young formally you
know do the same algorithm repeat the
same out charisma so the same algorithm
is what so now here I write it in terms
of the adjacency matrix of the graph
that I called G so G is one if I JS
imagine 0 otherwise just the same
algorithm as before is some overall case
now that are not high and not J say gee
I is 0 by definition of ji ka times fk2
I orgy is the adjacency matrix so this
is exactly the same graph as before the
same algorithm iteration as before
instead of restricting this sum over the
neighbors of I I just put these 01
variables here again world
okay now I claim that if you do a little
a little you know calculus and you
formally you know take the limit of
large graphs and this car stuff that is
of lower order terms the feeder
alliteration boils down to this up to
some normalizations so i will not do the
the calculus you can try to do it by
yourself or ready top it's it's not
important but it boils down to this this
is exactly the same as before except
that I normalize the adjacency matrix so
now I i take the adjacent symmetric and
the sine theta in such a way that is on
our average zero and that is scale it in
such a way that the variance is one so
aaj is 1 over square root of n is if i
JS imagine minus 1 over square root of n
otherwise so this is just the rescaling
is nothing important okay so this is the
same term before now what changes two
things I don't have any more determining
which i subtract j.c before I excluded
the J from the sum now I'm not excluding
J anymore okay because you say okay
you're excluding one-time out of n this
is not a big deal I can as well put them
all in now the important fact to remark
is that you know this is a cost that is
not negligible and you have to correct
with disk for this cost flow but with
the term of order 1 so the term of other
one is a constant the form of a memory
time where I put a constant times the
function evaluated at previous iteration
so there is another thing that changed
before variables were associated to
directed edges in the graph now
variables are directed associated to two
vertices in the graph now again this is
this is nothing you know magic I just
took this and expanded basically what
you do is a Taylor expansion in which
you see you write x IJ t as XIT plus
delta x IJ t so this is the naive gas
and then you say there is a small
correction when you carefully take into
account the correction there is this
other term that shows up and is of order
one in the limit basically there is a
term that is naively of order 1 square
root of n but so this kind of things is
well known in physics and this
correction is known as the own saga
reaction term and there is a formula for
this coefficient that is here it's not
important to parse is just a completely
explicit formula
okay so now this is a very neat simple
iteration that is interesting person I
with a vector X T in R to the N I apply
a nonlinear function and then I x my
random matrix and then i subtract a
memory turn and there are no metrics as
this properties for this case is
symmetric in expectation is during the
the standard the balance is 1 over N and
this function in this case you can
depend on the telephone number but but
is applied component twice so this is
what we call approximate message passing
because starts from message passing and
then is obtained by doing a few few
approximations so but somehow the
claimer or the ideas that this should
describe correctly the limit and to
infinity of of the message passing thing
for fourth iteration for dense graphs so
a few few few few references this kind
of reaction terms in physics is quite
quite old and its package list is being
last theory to foul sm there's an palma
that basically we're studying the esky
model for whoever of you knows what this
is and and you know brought the fixed
point equivalent of the equation that
that i wrote here for this specific
model in that case basically this
function f is a parabolic tangent
there were a few papers tried to use
this as an I creation some got it Bronk
some got it right kobashi my article got
it wrong and did it used it for this
sitting cdma problem and the few years
ago we kind of extended it having in
mind the compressed sensing application
and okay in this paper what I think
what's interesting is that we forgot
about the original motivation the
original motivation was computing
posteriors of a distribution here we
forgot about that we said we have this
general decoration you can choose your
function f anywhere you want so analysis
of this iteration is much more recent so
the first one really that the deed
rigorous analysis of this is a remote
island and not talk about it was that
look that balcony and the ski model we
extended the basically you know both
thousand eight years in a few directions
in several Direction few papers and and
with with master by attended algebra and
we mark the largely we did some cases at
least a non-gaussian a and the some
recent work that gives known asymptotic
result now I want to describe the dis
analysis because it's it's a it's a nice
idea
again the matrix a here will be Gaussian
so will be symmetric matrix that is 0 on
the diagonal and above the diagonal is
iid I'm three that I'll mean 0 and
variance 1 over N and the symmetric so
blow-dry agonal they're the same as
above so this is my setting now you can
forget about all the motivations and
wake up you take a back to life you
apply a function then you multiply by a
matrix right it's a reasonable thing to
do and then i subtract this magic memory
term now the interesting thing is that
what happens is that as in thought akali
so this is the theorem at least in this
setting then there is more general
statement as in protocol Adele this
vector X becomes Gaussian with mean 0
and the variance Sigma that you can
analyze its given by this recursion and
I'll describe the heuristic for this in
a minute okay so as emphatically this
vector access roughly iad Gaussian
component and you're the only assumption
of X is that it is lipschutz so let me
state this a little bit more formally so
what I mean by saying that vector axis
is I adoption I mean the following okay
this is one way of stating there is many
ways yeah yeah yeah yeah so here I
started the simplifying stuff to avoid
them but the theorem holds for F that is
time dependent and there are a few other
direction in which you can generalize it
Todd do other variables etc make it
vector valued but is not very
right so a bit for maladies is that if
you could look at the empirical measure
of the coordinate of X this converges
converges weekly to add a shunt measure
uncover just a little bit more than
weekly in in Buster Stein to distance
concretely this means that if you give
me any function any test function side
and functions is the condition that is
Lipschitz continuous and is bounded by 1
plus x squared then 1 over n sum over
right sigh of X I converges to the most
infinity the expectation of tsaia so you
can you can compute a lot of stuff using
this okay
so one word about realistic for this for
this theorem what is the distance is
very simple let's forget about this town
anywhere is an annoying term so let's
forget it doing a long argument so so
what what we want to say is that here we
are some a bunch of guys and these are
GU Shan's times coefficient now many
some a bunch of Gaussian you will obtain
a Goshen with balance that is some of
the balances well this is a squared over
N so this is central limit theorem now
as n goes to infinity this converges to
x lo large number two its expectation
done now of course this is wrong okay so
let's see let's see in an example why
this is wrong let's do it carefully
let's do it eration zero iteration one
direction zero you have a vector 30
let's say that we start with a fixed
initial condition all zero or old one
you apply this matter except now this is
nice this is correct a matrix Agathe
geometrics applied to a vector gives a
random random Gaussian vector with
basically I ed component all right so
iteration 1 done so in this case all all
all was good and and well now i'm trying
to do iteration 2 n running immediately
the problem because a and x 1 i've
dependent so i cannot apply the CLT
so what is this dis conditioning game
technique but my heroine is the
following idea that I think is very nice
okay i write this in a moment about this
by calling MSC just the back door f turn
60 and let me denote by by this funny
symbol the Sigma algebra generated by x0
x1 XD so what is the problem the problem
is that when I apply a to f of X T XT
and Sigma T are dependent exceed
measurable Sigma T but also a dependence
not independent so a and the past are
dependent so naively what you want to do
is is is fix a and compute the
distribution of a X but the right way to
think about it is you fix the past and
compute the conditional distribution of
a given the past so you think of it as
default in the following the observed T
step of your revolution you never
observed the matrix and now conditional
on this D step you conditioned you to
compute what is the distribution of the
matrix so this is as you see these are
alive okay you see me this relies a lot
on on on Gaussian matrices so so what
does it mean conditioning country
concretely water observe observe a
applied to a vector that is measurable
on my Sigma algebra gives one vector
blah blah blah I applied one vector
gives another vector that is measurable
so what you did what you did up service
really you made an observation that is a
sequence of linear functional of my
matrix a you can look this vector a
time's 70 a times empty months one as
linear functional of the matrix a so
what I'm really doing and conditioning
on the values of some linear functional
of a now if you have a Gaussian a
Gaussian object conditional the
conditional distribution given linear
function is very simple is the
conditional expectation plus the
projection of a new independent
the Gaussian orthogonal to the linear
operator right right so this this is
conditional expectation plus a projector
in computer projector and is something
of this form where pities while it's a
projector is the projector of a
complement on a space that is t
dimensional now when you apply a 2 to
the vector empty now i can rewrite it in
distribution as this a new hands you
know this projector plus the expectation
time-sensitive it is just a notation for
this conditional expectation this is the
conditional expectation of the matrix of
couplings given the previous iterations
so I'm not seeing the metric I'm just
seeing what's happening to my vectors
right now what happens here then is very
nice is that now you have a a Gaussian
random matrix that is independent of
this projector if you have a Gaussian
random matrix and then you project it
orthogonal to a space of dimension t
this is a projector of token outer space
of dimension T and T is more compared to
n while this projector is basically
letting the most of the matrix go
through
okay now now you do a lot of
calculations once your graph this idea
you can compute explicitly all the
conditional expectations etc and then
you have to do a a series of estimates
it is you know several you know some
some pages of work but but some magic
happens is that the piece that is so you
see here okay there is one piece that
now it's very nice because this is golf
shot because now you have a new
independent random and this is nice and
gosh on this pc you don't like because
it's your mess right but you do a bunch
of estimating you get the disc pieces
you know some of previous terms plus
exactly the term that you are going to
subtract so in my iteration i'm going to
subtract exactly this term this is the
onsager term so once i subtract this
there i left with these guys that just
by induction are Gaussian so your teeth
ratios that are Gaussian now I prove
that the T plus 1 is also gosh
okay yeah in question so this okay maybe
this helps answer the other question I
had which was was the theorem that for
any fixed T as n goes to infinity the
teeth iteration has this distribution so
what if you have you know a message
passing algorithm that takes say log n
steps to get the answer you want then
you know where order n steps would be
really worrisome if we're conditioning
on that much information right so so
yeah that's a good question so that is
this paper but I don't know yet I didn't
read it yet that some nuns are
sympathetic analysis but at some point
things must break down clearly and there
must be some fluctuation the analysis
that we did doesn't cover it but in
principle the technique is good enough
to doing it in the sense that you know
here we did everything every calculation
was exact except the going from this to
this doing this calculation here so this
calculation here is sticky basically
this messy formula and doing a bunch of
concentration of measure law of large
numbers etc and proving that the
remainders is smaller one so what I
claimed is that in theory few you know
use the same technique that should allow
you to get the final characterization
not claiming that anybody leave it and
and some of it is done in this paper
that letter cited but I don't know
exactly what they proved that is that
the answer yeah I mean I wish up already
so yeah what is that if you CN steps
then presumably you can reconstruct the
matrix yeah exactly so for but I would
assume that under conditions on F this
should be probably true you know for
instance if you are at an unstable fixed
point then this will break down when you
are when you do log n steps but if you
have stability a you know around the
deterministic solution then this
probably will go down up to some end to
some small power on potential
needs more lower bank steps and so are
we just too so I understand the natural
scaling so for problems on sparse graphs
we we need log n steps typically for
belief propagation to work in the dense
case to be typically only need other
scaling is the same it's the same but
the in publi or love that sparse graph
you don't need log n iteration to work
unless you are an unstable fixed at an
unstable fixed point right if it you are
at an unstable fixed point then you need
login iteration but if you are not there
basically you need constant number of
iterations okay yeah i guess i'm used to
problems like community detection where
you mean like if you are exactly the
symmetric point and there is an unstable
fixed part then you did you need
probably some log n iterations right and
this analysis as this will break down at
logon iteration at a stable fixed point
so okay so this is so this analysis as
you see was you know Betty I think it's
very interesting but it's based
crucially on this on this fact right
that if you take a Gaussian random
variable a new conditional back turn
your conditional linear functional you
get a simple characterization of it it's
conditional distribution what happens if
your matrix is not caution so this is
this theorem with with motion and Mark
large we prove basically the same thing
okay we assume you know some moment
conditions here and we have to assume
the most important thing that f is a
polynomial so my update function is a
polynomial and we have the same
conclusion okay so now the model of the
matrix is that is still symmetrix still
I hadn't entries above young the
diagonal with zero mean and end and body
on Swan oberlin and okay we assuming the
paper sub Gaussian entries but more
general okay so let me to explain the
technique let me take an event or an
extremely simple example f of X equal X
so here I'm doing something very simple
and taking a back term x matrix and if
you compute what is the the memory term
the orthogonal time is just subtracting
the vector at the previous iteration is
one of the simplest thing you might
might try to do now the corollary of
this theorem is that in this case xt is
Gaussian protein with mean 0 and
variance 1 okay now you know this is a
messy and easy but not trivial fact it's
an interesting fact right and let's go
about proving it how would we prove it
well a time one is simple someone they
say that the initial conditioning is all
one here you have an old one vector sign
minus one is zero this is zero so yet
you're taking your matrix and
minga rows of this matrix if you some
rows of a goe matrix you get Gaussian
random variable so time one done now
what happens at time to attend to and
thumbing your I'm computing computing a
times a times 1 this is X 0 i'm applying
a ones and applying a twice okay so this
this this product you can write it as
sum of a g1 and g2 of a i j 1 a j1 j2
and then there is the reaction term that
is minus 1 this is neo selected I can
take this term this son is no longer the
ocean or not obviously Gaussian because
it's sort of dependencies but what I'll
do is that I split the sum over the
second index / g 1 and g 2 into 2 times
the sum in which g to coincide with I so
get a ig1 a j1 j2 and then the sum in
which j2 is different from I so there is
the sum over J 2 different from j1 and I
sorry quick question so is your not just
taking powers of the matrix to do it
it's sometimes because of the term minus
one or the other wise which is you know
the spectrum you know Wigner yeah but
about the battle but you have the
indonesian the function is linear I can
I could do all of this exercise just
using the spectrum but that method will
not extend when I plan on linear
function right so now oh you're
preparing for a nonlinear but exactly so
I want to prove the linear case in a way
that then I can extend to nonlinear
salad is easier I can flip your question
and tell you that in this way I can
recover the service here called by
another proof I mean it's not an
entirely new proof because there is
people that did this kind
thing okay you'll see in a minute when
where you end up okay so you split this
summer so you have this some now so you
have two types of terms so one term is
these three vertices are distinct and
the other term is this the other some is
this one so this is the stuff now this
time is very easy right so this is
summer since the matrix is symmetric so
a j1 squared so by the law of large
numbers said this is basically one since
all of this is very balanced 1 over N so
this guy cancels exactly dead guy and I
claim that what is left approximately is
just the sum over these fellows and I
claim that you know you can prove just
for instance by moment method the disc
converges to a gaussian and the
underlying reason is that there is
enough independence once you eliminated
this reversing terms there is enough
independence across multiple choices of
g1 and g2 to prove the central limit
theorem
if I want to do the same fourth
iteration what you obtain what you
obtain is that once you your work out of
the consolation is that X I is the sum
of our you know when you take a to the K
way to the field this is the sum over
all paths gamez of the of length T of
the product of a k-12 t minus one of a
gamma K they are McKinnon's one if I
simply take a matrix and raise it to
power T you get the sum over all the
gammas that our paths in the complete
graph rooted at vertex I and of length T
over weight and the weight is the
product of the matrix and tracy's along
the path ok so one term will be one path
will be I know gamma 1 you have my tool
what I claim is that this this simple
subtraction what it does is basically it
eliminates all the paths that are
reversing so eliminate all the paths
except the ones that have satisfied this
condition for any K gamma kimmons one is
different from gamma k plus 1 and and
once you get this then you use moment
method on this exciting and you get get
convergence too ok now the claim is that
now i'm almost out of time but the same
proof basically works for any polynomial
function so what happens for a
polynomial function suppose that
chocolate into a simple case to post
that down your function for instance is
x squared after one iteration water to
iteration good a times seven times a
times the vector one this is what is
some other component I of this vector is
sum over J somewhere l 1 and l 2 of a i
j aj l1 aj l2 in other words this
operation is is the following is not the
sum over all the paths but the sum over
all tryst with this topology rooted at I
where each tree is weighted by the
product of the matrix entries along the
tree and what this magic term is doing
is reducing this sum to the sum over all
no reversing tree so I'm subtracting
from this from the summer three all the
trees in which you know when you do one
step on the future you come back to the
previous step
so this is what this is it formerly the
not ever seen three are you know
somewhere all the labeling of the
vertices of tea with labels value nine
such that gamma the root of the label of
the rooted I and the root the label of a
descendant of the different from from
the label of a parent of V for every
burst xfinity so this is what this term
is doing is translating the sum of the
trees in sum over no reversing trees and
once you have this then again now you
have this object you computer my power
of this object you complete the
expectation of the power you do some
combinatorics and then you get the
moment of the Gaussian the size of those
trees depends on the degree of that
polynomial yes so this is for any fix a
polynomial and forever fixity again a
good question is can we you know exactly
as you so I mentioned very quickly that
people did things of similar type when
they compute spectrum of random matrices
for instance I think Sasha Saudi as this
this this this way of doing and you know
in that case they are able to push it
beyond computing the just constant power
but larger power and this keeps the
extreme of the spectrum and in praise of
all one could take these and go further
in that direction that that's an
interesting direction yeah play a second
term to get the person just approximate
any lucious so so good question so can
you approximate idea whip I think it's
easier than the conditioning which
breaks down after guarantee
well so this will break down when the
story gets too large because at some
point the combinatorics will be break
down so what happens basically is that
when you compute these trees the same
happens when you compute when you do
spectrum of random matrices by moment
method so you get that the only terms
that matters are the one in which it
charges visited that is visited is
visited exactly twice so so now how to
do lift its function and one would like
to approximate any Lipschitz function by
polynomial the tricky part is that you
cannot approximate the function on the
real line uniformly with a polynomial
you can approximate it just non
uniformly right with respect to some
Gaussian thing I think it's also now
there is no did the approximation gets
bad at infinity now you have to control
your random variable and show the fact
that the fact that gets better the
infinitely doesn't hurt you too much I
think it's it's in principle it's an
interesting direction but we didn't try
to do it we were lazy the way we apply
these normal is we take the function
that we want to do that is a non
polynomial we approximated with the
polynomial we prove all the bounds that
we want and at the end of the day we let
the approximation error in polynomial so
we don't prove the evolution of a non
polynomial but we only do it at the end
of of the whole proof so we don't have a
theorem of this type
alright so I'm out of extensions or
perhaps I just flush this slide yeah so
one thing is that that you know several
people used it and extended this to
apply to it to a bunch of other problems
so in compact sensing for instance you
know people that were active in these
are flan lank added several paper and
compressed sensing and set of paper and
matrix estimation jamming as a paper in
which uses this forum for this sparse
sparse graph problems and this process
skip over this example conclusion with
some more open problems yeah so so no as
I said one minute ago one nice nice
problem would be to the non polynomial f
we die erde matrices and potentially in
the paper we are lazy with the
combinatorics and with the subduction
entries which should be possible with
prop 6 or some some finite number of
moments there are reason to believe that
similar similar type of things can be
done for very tricky and ensembles or
one very tricky ensemble would be but
feasible will be you take a random
orthogonal matrix with her measure and
perhaps you take the first delta x n
rows okay and then use that as your
mango matrix on you use that matrix
times its transpose okay and there is
there is for instance a physics paper
the new rigorous paper by Manfred opera
and quarters in which they get a the
right evolution for this kind of a Samba
another interaction that would be very
interested for me to do F here I'm
assuming always have to be a separable
function so applies coordinates x
coordinate you could look at them know
several functions
is the reaction term outside return is a
difference for when you apply the
subsample for you a free air mattress
nobody knows but but these people did it
for four sections of heart what I mean
by this is subsampled are uniformly
random and you get a different times so
you can't apply the same order to
produce it's the same what what changes
is this be be object instead of being is
always a function of 1 over n sum over I
F prime of X I accept that is not just
that object is a funk rock that object
that is related to water and it's hard
to Prudhoe he doesn't work for yeah yeah
yeah I mean for general it's Eddie also
so all of this should be the same and
not okay so one thing that is surprising
for me is that this is that also works
if you take F that is not separable for
instance you can do they are very weird
functions in which you know you take
your vector and then you project it on
the corner of semi definite you look at
it as a matrix so you make it to a
matrix and you project it on the corner
of semi definite matrices this is a
highly non separable function so that
means your take the single the
eigenvalue decomposition and then put 20
the eigen values that are less than 0
this is a highly not separable function
from point of your physics doesn't make
much sense but but make sense for some
of these applications and and all of
these works very well empirically I mean
the evolution works well empirical
the key point that make it works because
you don't have to generate two strong
correlation between the variables right
so is there any measurable observable on
F which says me why it should be it
should be you're nice in the sensor so
it should be Lipschitz continuous for
instance something that you want and you
know for instance a young one that is an
extension that is Easy's when you take F
and the axial block by block on your
vector right so so that I think it's an
extension that is not too are now each
each variable on the output should
depend on a few variables on the input
but really this is very hydrating
thank you